niles huge you're the first
black live-action prince in the disney
universe
what does that feel like it's amazing um
because i know you know growing up i
really didn't get to see that when i was
younger
uh you know my first experience really
with that was seeing chadwick
as black panther and i remember that
impact it had on me and how emotional i
was leaving the theater
uh you know so to be able to
do that or you know hopefully something
similar to the impact chadwick had on me
it's going to be really good because i
think we need to see more of us
normalized you know being royalty being
you know a superhero stuff like that how
big of an impact did chadwick have on
you all the
beautiful work that he did on and off
camera is that something that you're
gonna use to channel
you know in the years to come in your
career yeah i mean
one thing about about chadwick that
really spoke to me was how he
he made everybody feel important uh
that's something that seems to be
a resounding thing when i talk to people
that when they talk to chadwick
it was like they were the only person in
the room i've always
prided myself on treating everybody like
they're equal
you know i i feel like in this industry
specifically too
um you know people will treat people
differently based on the level that
they're at
uh and i've always been anti that and
you know
seeing that chadwick was like that and
not only that he was very educated
and his approach to acting that's why
i'm going to college
for uh for film because i want to be
able to understand behind the camera
i'll be able to be more of an honest
actor uh with when having an
understanding of
what directors and stuff and what anna
had to go through to be able to make
this film
royalty by day hero by night
it sounds pretty dope the secret society
of second born royals what was it like
making this movie
an amazing experience uh and a journey
that i feel like we came out the other
side you know you know better for it uh
like we had to train we had to go over
stunts we had to
you know go to a new uh place we'd never
been before
and of doing this together i feel like
it was an amazing journey
i have such faith that this movie is
going to be huge
and that it's going to catapult you guys
to a new level of stardom
are you ready for that i'm more ready
for the platform
and what i can use uh you know
i want to be able to talk more and be
more honest and
be open about the trials and
tribulations because uh
you know acting is cool but you know
there's a lot of things that come with
it
that i feel like aren't talked about
especially when you are a child coming
up in this industry
and i really want to talk about that uh
you know not just
that but you know doing that as a black
man you know so
you know i'm more ready for that like
that's something that i'm i'm really
looking forward to because
you know there's a difference between
being viewed at as an actor and then
being viewed as nice fitch who
acts you know uh and that's gonna be a
weird transition but you know i got my
family around me and i got isabella
folly peyton olivia skyler you know all
of them
and you know we're going to protect each
other through all this because uh it's
going to be it's going to be a lot like
it's
it is where the fairy tale ends
is where our story begins
you